hey what is up guys i'm kbhd here and
i've done some smartphone roundups some
camera comparisons in the past i've done
these very objective very numerical
evaluations of how good the camera
performance was and what these things
are capable of but that was back in 2014
now that it's 2017 smartphone cameras
have gotten so good that the difference
between the top five best smartphone
cameras meaning the ones that you buy
because you take a lot of photos and
videos the difference is so small it's
gotten so small that the difference is
way less about like objective
differences in performance like better
or less dynamic range or more or less
megapixels and it's more just about
personal preference which one you think
looks a little bit better maybe one has
some software features you like or maybe
one has a little bit of a different hue
it just looks a little better in the
colors so to prove that i have the top
five best smartphone cameras out here
and i've taken identical photos with all
of them a bunch of them from the exact
same angles and you decide the winner
and you're supposed to be honest with
yourself so don't skip to the end of the
video start right here and we're going
to go through a b
c d and e
and you can see if you can pick one of
them that you like better than the
others you can look at what you like
about sharpness and detail or dynamic
range or just colors or maybe just just
look at it and pick the one you like
that looks better so pro tip go ahead
and watch this in as high resolution as
you can go ahead and click down here in
the bottom corner and if you can watch
it in 1440p do that if you can watch it
in 4k do that that'll give you the best
look at these photos let's take a look
all right so this first one is a
backpack and it's outdoors on a bench
and the biggest thing you're going to
notice between these is actually the
color temperature and contrast so just
looking at that black pocket that center
square is supposed to be black but you
can notice in each of the pictures
there's a little bit of a different
color cast bit of a different hue
and the sharpness and the detail levels
are about the same in and out of focus
and the background is about the same but
you'll notice the color temperature is
the biggest differentiator so here's
your side by side in case that helps
pause it if you need to look at it and
moving on so this is another outdoor
picture and there's a little bit less
colors but the same effect you'll see a
little bit more this is a gray car but
as you can see in each of the individual
shots the car and the ground which is
the asphalt varies again with the color
the yellow lines get a little bit warmer
or cooler on each shot but for the most
part the exposure and the sharpness are
about the same again the plants on the
front the colors on the back you better
judge here's a side by side again for
those who want to see it pause it if you
need it and moving on now this is a
portrait so a lot of people when you're
looking at portraits you can look at
again colors and things like skin tones
my skin tones are different in every
single one of these so you can check
that out and i'm also wearing a pretty
vibrant shirt so you can see how the
cameras and the image processing helps
with that but for the most part it's an
in focus foreground a slightly out of
focus background and just a little bit
of a focus on the colors for the
portrait a little bit softer and some a
little bit sharper in others here's the
side by side for those who want it pause
it if you need it and moving on now this
one's a pretty distinct foreground and
background shot so i'm taking a portrait
here so you guys can see how blurred out
the backgrounds get and smartphones
these days have really wide apertures f
1.9 1.8 1.7 even so a lot of these are
doing a really good job you can see to
the extent and the degree that they blow
out the background and of course you get
a sense of white balance as well with
the different colors and shades of the
white of the table so again you can take
a look at this side by side pause it if
you need it
and next now here's another portrait and
we're outdoors and it's a little bit
contrastier but again the bigger
difference if you notice here is the
difference in color on the white wall
the black asphalt and then just the
color of the jacket it kind of changes
with coolness or warmness based on the
color temperature again but yeah overall
a pretty similar shot in each one as far
as sharpness goes because again
everything's in focus but you can notice
the differences in image processing just
based on the way the colors look so
again here's your side by side of each
single one pause it if you need it
moving on now this is a bit of a lower
light photo and this is where the best
smartphone cameras or cameras in general
can actually excel and separate
themselves from the lower end so for
this one you're looking at the tones in
groot's little face and if you want to
look at noise reduction you can look at
his eyes and the black shelf that he's
sitting on the rest of it is a little
bit of the cast in the hues and there's
a backlight behind him on a white wall
but you can see to the extent that they
blow up groot's face or don't
and also if you want the side by side
here is that again you can see the tone
differences and moving on now this one's
a landscape uh to the extent that i
could do a landscape on such a dreary
day like this but you can see the empire
state building there in the background
and for landscapes you really want to
focus on just detail so if you're
counting windows on the empire state
building you have a pretty good idea
that this one gets sharpness well but
again the color differences is what i
notice as the biggest difference here as
well so look at the colors of the cement
on each one and then we'll get this side
by side
and moving on so last but not least i
think this is the the tell-all or the
most revealing photo you want to keep an
eye on two things on this one the top
tones of the steering wheel it's an
all-black interior and over on the left
in the rear view mirror the amount that
you can see that american flag in the
mirror in some it's a little bit
overexposed in others it's perfectly
visible so you can see which ones have
the most dynamic range or which ones
have the most pleasing image but again
here is the side by side of the center
point which was the steering wheel which
is the part that i tapped to focus on
when i took the photo
and that is it so now that you've seen
all the comparisons you've made your
pick by now which one is your top choice
maybe leave it in the comments section
below was it a b c d or e
and this is the phone you picked
that
is your top choice for a smartphone
camera so does your winner surprise you
at all probably not because these are
among the best smartphone cameras the
reason why they were chosen was because
they have good cameras and they're all
very similar in that regard but a lot of
times people just have a little bit of a
bias they don't want to pick one and
they end up picking it i think what
happens when we go into a lot of these
head-to-head comparisons is we go in
knowing which one we want to win so we
see a side by side of phone a and phone
b and we know we like phone a and we
want to justify it being better in our
hearts so every little difference that
looks better about phone a's picture
than phone b's we will say to ourselves
okay that makes it better and we just
ignore everything that's good about
phone b it's a basic confirmation bias
and we just kind of assume the new one
is better even if we don't know that for
sure we might actually like a different
phone than we thought we did a lot of
people go into it saying oh i hate the
iphone i'd never pick it i bet a lot of
you pick the iphone so hopefully this
sheds a little bit of light on the fact
that they're all really damn good
and there's other things that of course
go into picking a smartphone even just
for the camera i've gone over them in
the past just autofocus speed uh
software features time lapse features
stabilization all these things when
taking a video even the selfie camera is
important all i went over in this one is
just raw back facing camera performance
anyway let me know what you think thank
you for watching and i'll talk to you
guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you